welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and while episode 3 of the new Obi-Wan
Kenobi series on Disney plus ended on a
super shocking note the biggest shock of
the show still belongs to that of
episodes 2 ending that saw the death of
the grand Inquisitor at the hands of the
badass Savage of a third sister a murder
that many in the Star Wars Community
have assumed to be a huge retcon of the
Star Wars Rebels continuity that also
portrays an apparent end of the grand
inquisitor's life as well but what about
told you that there is a possibility
that absolutely nothing was retconned in
that everything is going exactly
according to the dark evil plans of the
sea if well let's explore the endless
Dark Side of possibilities together my
nerd babies but first consider exploring
the light side of the force with our new
Obi-Wan Kenobi inspired shirts at
newrockstarsmirch.com they're amazing
and I love the design and they're not
gonna last forever so please head on
over to new rockstarsmerch.com to pick
one up today so you can say hello there
and start now I think the best way to
start off this video is to recap all the
times that we've sort of seen the grand
inquisitor's supposed final fate in Star
Wars Canon because so far I think we've
seen three instances I think we should
probably take these in chronological
order in the Star Wars timeline just to
make things easier now the first and
obviously most fresh instance at the
Grand Inquisitor supposedly meets his
death on the Star Wars timeline is of
course when Reva gots him into the
gutter at the end of episode two
dude
[Music]
who's in the gutter now however somehow
this Grand Inquisitor would survive a
fatal Blow from this highly trained
assassin and live long enough to
seemingly meet his demise again in Star
Wars Rebels This Time by allowing
himself to fall to his death rather than
deal with the wrath of Darth Vader for
his repeated failures to thwart this
Canon Jairus fellow there are some
things far more frightening than death
oh
foreign
but that's only two instances that we've
thought we've seen as final fate so far
and for a lot of people this is where
they believe the story of the grand
Inquisitor ends in Star Wars Canon but
that's not actually the case because you
see this nameless Grand Inquisitor
fellow was extremely special to Darth
Vader's heart well not really he didn't
give up about that man he actually
didn't really like him so special in
fact that Vader straight up refused to
let catch you on die you Caillou die
after falling into that fiery Abyss in
Star Wars rebels in the first place oh
no my nerve babies for you see the last
known person the grand Inquisitor has
been known to actually fight in Star
Wars Canon is the adult Luke Skywalker
himself years after this for you see in
the pages of 2020 Star Wars number six
we learned that after Darth Vader
dropped his son's lightsaber and the
Annoying hand attached to it down a big
old bespin hole in Empire Strikes Back
Luke Skywalker actually made his way to
an old Jedi Outpost from the days of the
high Republic where he was greeted by
the fiery ghost of one grand inquiser
with his Soul seemingly being tied to
this Jedi Temple my Darth Vader himself
basically as a security system to
destroy anyone foolish enough to fall
for this Jedi Treasure Trove of a booby
trap but of course Luke Skywalker would
best this Grand Inquisitor quite easily
in fact with Vader after telling his
failure of a dead ghost servant that he
would never allow the grand Inquisitor
to go to the afterlife as long as he
could help it call in the grand
Inquisitor nothing but a tool shaped to
serve his purpose even when the grand
Inquisitor was begging for death he just
wanted to die there are some things far
more frightening than death why does
this all matter well Obi-Wan isn't the
only one with homework in this series in
your Solitude on Tatooine training I
have for you Qui-Gon how to commune with
him I will teach you Anakin Skywalker
ended Revenge of the Sith with his own
Force homework from his own old ass
Force user as well whereas Obi-Wan has
spent the last decade trying to get his
Qui-Gon Senpai to notice him Master
Quest
If Ever I needed guidance Master it's
now MasterCard Master are you there
Master help me master no just me said
bye
please Darth Vader has likely been
spending the last 10 years learning the
secrets to conquering death as tease to
him at the end of Darth sidious's
retelling of the tragedy of Darth
Plagueis the Wise with Darth Plagueis of
course being Insidious his former master
that he murdered in his sleep after
learning those juicy dark secrets to
cheating death that now only he knows
secrets that Palpatine promised to pass
down to Anakin Skywalker if you were to
ever decide to you know casually betray
everyone that he ever loved and start a
new fascist regime built on fear one day
and spoiler alert that's exactly what
Anakin decides to do did all that to
save Padme ended up choking her what an
idiot don't put that in however up until
recently it wouldn't be hard to assume
that Anakin Skywalker fell for the worst
and most deadly snake oil sale of all
time from Darth Plagueis but with
Palpatine actually cheating death
himself in Rise of Skywalker there is
actually now concrete proof that
Palpatine really did unlock the secret
to cheating death and he did this for
himself specifically through the
transfer of his Consciousness and soul
through the dark side of the Force into
a cloned body of his own making on the
dark Sith planet of exigo like this was
Palpatine's contingency plan that was
meant to kick in the moment he ever died
and is likely the secret to cheating
death that he has been teaching his
Apprentice Darth Vader to do much like
he promised him at the Opera many moons
ago however if one is going to
experiment on how to cheat death you
kinda need a life to experiment on
because you can't really experiment with
your own life because well if you fail
then that's the end of learning how to
cheat death because you're dead so this
all being said and especially knowing
now how much Darth Vader has learned
about using the dark side of the force
to preserve one's life force by the time
period of The Empire Strikes Back it
makes so much sense to me that what
we're experiencing in this Obi-Wan
series are Darth Vader's
experimentations with life force
manipulations via the never-ending
servitude of one grand Inquisitor
probably due to the more durable bodies
and longer lives if the grand
inquisitor's powen species live like
powens can live up to 700 years after
all and since we learn in the
Mandalorian that the emperor was kind of
struggling to create a perfect vessel
for himself through the cloning of human
beings specifically his own DNA it
wouldn't be impossible to reason that
the bodies of the more longer live power
race might be more friendlier to the
cloning process because let's be honest
here using this Logic the grand
inquisitor's death in episode 2 of the
series is probably not even the first
time that he died like I bet Vader and
the emperor have been repeatedly
transferring the consciousness of this
Grand Inquisitor into new cloned bodies
because he was just too damn good at his
job but also most importantly not
powerful enough to take Vader's spot on
the emperor's side as his right hand man
because if you read the Star Wars comics
Vader kind of never really wanted the
inquisitors in the first place they were
kind of thrust upon him by the emperor
to catch all these four sensitive people
in the Galaxy so I really don't think
Vader really wants anybody but the
Grant's Inquisitor to be the grand
Inquisitor because let's be real dark
side users are always out for themselves
and I am confident that we will see this
character's return in a cloned Body by
the end of the series because like I
said before this dude got stabbed close
Distance by a member of the
inquisitorious like back to tanks are
good but I don't think any back to tank
is that good it's all about the Clones
baby but that is why I believe the grand
Inquisitor still shows up in further
Star Wars Canon past the Obi-Wan Kenobi
series what do you guys think let us
know in the comment section below my
beautiful nerd babies but thank you guys
so much for watching this video you can
follow me at Mass retainment on Twitter
if you want to see me tweet some weird
[ __ ] and really fun theories but more
importantly you can follow the new
rockstars wherever we are on the
internet especially YouTube when you do
on YouTube make sure you hit that
notification Bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video and of course hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com for our new Obi-Wan
Kenobi inspired shirt and all of our
other amazing merch options over there
and it's a great way to support the
channel because it helps us out a ton
thank you guys so much for watching this
video I love you guys so much and I'll
see you guys next time goodbye foreign
[Music]